voters will go to the polls in France
Sunday it is a presidential election
that could have far-reaching
consequences for Europe poll shows
centrist and manual McCraw leading for
far-right candidate marine lepen several
people were detained this morning after
they unfurled a banner on the Eiffel
Tower Mark Phillips is in Paris ahead of
the pivotal vote mark good morning
good morning well it is the last day of
campaigning here before this weekend's
vote and it turns out not just the
candidates are trying to influence the
electorate in fact one of the voices
that has entered the fray you might find
familiar Paris woke up this morning to
discover its most symbolic structure has
become a political billboard the banner
hung by the environmental group
Greenpeace in containing the French
national slogan was widely interpreted
as support for the centrist candidate
Emmanuel macron and against his
right-wing anti-immigrant opponent
marine lepen she continues to trail by
an apparently insurmountable 20 or so
points in the polls and her chances
weren't helped by another intervention
also Barack Obama's that I am supporting
Emmanuel macron to lead you forward on
mosh people across but the pen is not
giving up in an election cycle that
produced the Donald Trump victory in the
United States this is the aged
supporters like Colleen Moo main hope of
unlikely upsets you know because Trump
it has been exactly the same thing maybe
six months ago
and everybody say that Hillary would win
and she didn't so there's still a chance
you know and lepen has been running a
campaign right out of the Donald Trump
playbook attacking Mac Pro at a heated
and sometimes ugly debate we have gone
Tufts all that mass was suggesting he
had squirreled away money in an offshore
account she admitted she had no evidence
and a furious macro has launched a legal
complaint fake news he called it the
eggs that were thrown at marine lepen
yesterday missed the poll predictions
for Sunday's vote may be more on the
mark
in fact the gap in the polls has become
so large that Emmanuel macron main enemy
might be complacency marine lepen voters
will come out on Sunday Mac brawl has to
convince his voters not to stay home all
right all right mark Phillips in Paris
thank you so much